here's a way you could approach it right
um just in case you need to understand
the question they tell you they're
filling up like a pool or something
right ya feel at lunch some large
container this is the number of plants
that are feeding in and using that
number of plants this is how long it
takes okay so it clearly looks like it's
a comparison of rates right it's a
comparison rate and usually you usually
for example if i say let's let's do a
different question if i say oh it takes
me three hours to go 100 kilometers in
my car okay because it's a really bad
traffic okay if you take well you know
what if I went for twice as long and I
went for six hours well it's reasonable
there to say oh I will travel twice as
far right so you apply your normal sort
of rates thinking you multiply both by
two everything's happy okay then you
come to this question now I'm going to
do the wrong way first when you add the
extra pipes how many pipes are there
down in total there are 20 times now if
you apply this kind of logic right this
is like more time more kilometers so
when you look over here it doesn't seem
that crazy to think more pipes equals
well now let's think of this right now
here's where the answer has gone right
how do you turn 12 into 20 what do you
multiply 12 by to turn it into 25 really
i think i think it's five thirds thanks
five go 25 or 35 ever three Shh they
were the other so what the solution is
done essentially has simple okay I'll
just multiply this by five thirds and
therefore i guess i multiply this by
five bucks we should times it okay ah
now five thirds that's going to be 40
over 3 which i think is 13 and third
okay 13 hours 20 minutes right but of
course because I put it in comparison
you can immediately see something is
going wrong lately yeah it's like why
why is this taking longer when you've
got more it's like it's like the law of
group work the more people you add the
less work the group does okay um this is
clearly full ok this is clearly fought
so this can't be the answer it's company
on sir so this is not just as easy as i
just multiply through ok so be that we
know what the answer isn't how do we
actually go about well now I'd like you
if you got your own paper there to pick
up your pen and I want you to think
about this with you remember we said ok
there is going to be 20 water place in
total that's what I'm interested in ok
that's a bit of a funny kind of finicky
number to work with so before I actually
solved that question I'm just going to
simplify it a bit suppose I had 24 right
this is exactly the situation i gave you
over here like I'm doubling something
right so you don't double the pipes so
you don't even need to do any
calculations really how long is it going
to take to fill up the bar it'll take
four hours now pause for a second where
did you get that number from don't just
shout an answer out tell me where you
get this answer from on the best of the
numbers i already have here ok so when
you've got more clothes right twice as
many if you want to think about it this
way what's happening in here is it fills
up twice as fast so that's why this
takes half the time does that make sense
we're done ok so we actually have a
fancy word for this this is called um an
inverse proportion so as something gets
bigger something else gets smaller ok so
that's a very simple example very
principle because doubling is easy so
now we're ready to add some our actual
question ok that is not just neatly
double it's not even nearly
half but you told me before when we're
doing the question wrong that to get
from here to here you should multiply by
5 thirds you remember that not far off
finish this so therefore over here we
saw multiple my five thirds let's not
give you the right time you'll get more
time but just like from here to here you
multiply by two here two here you divide
by two so I'm going to be five thirds
faster than when I was here before so
therefore this should be 8/5 that okay
now when you thread it into your
calculator don't expect any of you will
do that you'll get four point eight
hours now just pause from of it based on
what we've looked at does that intuition
make sense well number one it's quick up
there moments ago and number two oh of
course it has to be a bit over four
hours cuz you get 24 hours you'd need
twice as many plants you don't quite
have that much okay now one last thing
to finish that's basically Deion's I'd
be happy with that that's quite a lot of
thinking to get there however we don't
usually say oh yes that'll take three
point two hours okay or four point eight
hours we don't usually put them in
decimal so thankfully your calculator
has a button exactly for this you're
just used to seeing it with angles this
just breaks things up into chunks of 60
and then terms of 60 again minutes and
seconds so if you have this on your
calculator screen and you just hit that
button it's going to tell you this
whoops which is four hours and 48
minutes